welcome to this video agent Fox Mulder
yep played him before and have got four
wins and no draw no loss that that was
played against me recently bye-bye my
way and I really had issues with this
what do we it move what about check
let's try that okay and if he's making
some kind of Smith more out of it okay
melees also pre move or something and
are directed against the premium so that
that might might well be Bishop g5 here
so somebody might pre-move knight c6 or
a six or something like that okay so
let's see ever now he's ready to push it
five yeah nice d file also what's so
possible hmm okay what if i go here that
instead an idea just step out of this
not retreating i mean ii five 594 i
guess
yeah i think if I've not you for should
work now okay so d60 I'm preventing a 54
for good I'm ready to Castle short yeah
I really think this is more or less just
an extra porn without any particular
compensation at least I don't I don't
see it really
yep I have e5 dome okay let's do it
this night no not really 95 is not a
threat i have work the aid if i don't
see anything better the only thing that
worries me a bit is that Queen on h5 it
doesn't have many squares and on a very
bad day it might get might get trapped
okay I'm taking on d5 and back and then
his Bishop gets some additional activity
i will from a structural point of view
that's great we should be 5v5 night b8
he might have 90 form my can't read
Queens though okay I had something that
i should say if you watch my videos
continuously the last game the game
before that was a loss that I did not
upload it was a Saved by the Bell game
we had started the game and then someone
only not someone there either what's
what's the name actually postman yeah
the postman right um what's ringing and
there was some problem with them a
package and it took so long to sort out
that I was hopelessly low on time and
couldn't do anything I am it wasn't
worth uploading plus you have the
conversation with the there was a
mailman Karl Malone was always the
mailman right so it's probably the
mailman anyway yeah you have my whole
conversation with that guy on on the
video so that doesn't make much sense to
upload okay um what is this just be six
here or that 94 move this retaining me
still maybe rooks e7 but then I wonder
if he can maybe take only five some
something something crazy to use my
slightly hampered coordination can also
do this just give him that porn
let's do it i get b 2 back and I'm
activate it
the remaining poncy I mean the structure
is pretty pretty sturdy and I've got
this this rook active we should be eight
to be success also something that would
be nice to get in I'm not sure about
this if I'd really should have done that
giving it point back but it feels rather
rather active and 94 is still a move
that irritates me quite a bit this one
okay he's kind of I don't know 36 maybe
just G 694 words i think more irritating
ok so it's giving me two moose here
basically for free let's see if i can
get to that be six square and the Queen
as Queen Queen a three and then moves
like that but I wanted to get out of
that 94 idea anyway so no no big issue
at least I hope its obligation
okay so we can actually trade stuff here
if I go no SG for PSG form if I move the
light oh wow it's actually pretty
interesting Queen sacrifice it would be
a introduced that set some compensation
really I come on em I'm always
fascinated by such ideas g4 Queen h4 hun
or it doesn't even do it that was my
idea was interesting maybe not enough
objectively but it's a it's always to be
temperature was tempting to to place
such things if they are somewhat
somewhat possible somewhat possible
means that it's not objectively correct
but but interesting to try okay um it's
got 92 this 96 that I have to take care
of that night on h7 is not playing at
all
not sure we should be three may be
threatening discover ism okay I don't
know where is he going to a five no not
really good morning guessing any any
office moves sort of pinning here and
under then it's got queen bee six maybe
I can actually activate this here night
a form yeah okay that letter that's a
very decent very decent endgame the
night on c5 oh my blundering stuff
that's not good that's bad what did I
blunder that the bloody paw never had a
great endgame there that's not so clear
actually can get getting this bag I can
maybe do something on the second rank
him know what am I doing here hey I'm
just giving later whoops wow I walks
into a storm it's have a completely
stupid game ha I no no no no no yeah so
that was interesting i think that that
94 means that was was was a problem Oh
bishop h4 was also good here for him
yeah it's probably probably I have to do
bishop dat am and this is also good for
black hair I don't I don't really
believe in that year with the bishop
this Bishop looking at a porn and this
Bishop looking at a part that that
cannot be great for white so Bishop the
aid yeah
and here is the combined possibility
self bishop age four and 94 there are 22
annoying so this is what the engine is
giving with G for being an ID em now
that's strong it's a strong I mean this
isn't check probably the best practical
chance but I've got three points but
that's not good really because I mean
he's threatening 94 and those pieces are
ridiculous now okay that's good for
white very good void yeah he wrote here
I'm okay but difficult to play yeah I
had to had planned this I wanted to
sacrifice the Queen here I thought that
was interesting maybe it just totally
crazy this idea of it if I thought that
it could be interesting because i get i
get lied to hear attacking this looking
at this and night on c5 so the remaining
pieces are really active but probably
it's objectively not enough but he
didn't he didn't do that he went to the
capture here yeah yeah i'm certainly ok
but it was it was a crazy time time
thing him yeah I simply didn't see 95
what is good here look a far if you just
keeping things check this is thing is
the structure that black has really
really nice d 5 is weak a to this week
1993 ideas also in it was just a crazy
time scrambler at the end okay well
thanks for watching